alex jones wants to talk about
conspiracy theories the vaccine and
really what's going on all right alex
let's go
infowars.com infowars.com i have warned
you about these vaccines and it is
absolutely a miracle it is a miracle
death serum
of chimera combinations let me tell you
something these globalists got a plan
and we ain't it it's bill gates master
plan the sterilization of eugenics labs
and depopulation summit 20 years ago
it's all out there it's all on
infowars.com
you're one of these guys who says the
government's up to something
i snuck into bohemian grove in the year
2000 i was with bbc affiliates i was
with a secret service
i saw satanist republicans burning the
effigy of the owl god moloch i saw
faustian rituals of
old men doing deep breathing in circles
[Music]
and what i what i realized was this is
multi-level it's corruption it's
blackmail
it's the scientists elite that want to
dictate culture they want they want your
body they want to control your behavior
i mean everybody's got a little bit of
time on the planet who would want to
waste their life
controlling everyone's behavior this is
ridiculous what is
what is the end game what do they want
the end game
is 2030 post human post-industrial
allegory of the collapse of society
listen
people gave up on god these are the same
people that gave up on god these are the
abject psychopathic demons these are the
dark
evil possessed people that feed off of
dark energy and i'm not playing games
here
i'm not playing no i know you're not the
only person playing games here is bill
gates and actually
speaking of games i do have a bill gates
this or that game to play you want to
test your knowledge of the satanic
globalist bill gates
sure i'll test my knowledge i don't know
much less
all right let's put your reptilian
satanist hats on so
we went ahead and asked bill gates would
you rather eat a dozen babies
or slaughter civilization
did bill gates say eat a dozen babies
or slaughter civilization we know he
loves doing both we know he looks right
but what's the most important yeah what
does he like better only pick one
i think he wants a slaughter
civilization slaughter civilization
let's see
bill gates would you slaughter
civilization or
eat a dozen babies eat babies has
energy to destroy civilization
oh i'm so sorry i gotta tell you i'm
cool
that was a fun game but i feel it was
rigged it was a trick question really
i mean you're saying he's gonna eat the
babies and then get the powers to
destroy the world so all right
that work yeah we asked the demon
himself the demon said what he said and
i'm sorry you're lost
listen i gotta go take a piss i'll be
right back
right bye-bye hold on my guy oh i guess
i'm doing a commercial all right i was
gonna go pitch but i guess now i gotta
go do a commercial listen
what you need is ultra sun fusion it's a
mixture of toothpaste in wt40
it is full of vitamin w it's great for
saliva production great for bone growth
this will help you fight the globalists
help you fight all the diseases that
they're unleashing into the world
to create a post-human apocalyptic world
only at infowars.com
infowars.com infowars
we have to get your production